hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time to delve
into one of the most intriguing
existences within the entirety of Fanta
hunter which resides within the second
youngest child of silver and kikyo
zoldak in the infinitely powerful nanika
and in this video we are going to get
into the gritty of exactly what nanika
is because for anime only fans that
little fact it might still remain a
mystery but in the manga we've actually
been given an astounding amount of
information to work with leading to what
I feel is a very very solid conclusion
now when a locket and non-car were
introduced into the story it was like
nothing Honda hunter had ever seen
before because what they are I suppose
what nanika specifically represents is a
sort of godlike power that not even a
being like marijuana could have hoped to
attain nanika is for all intents and
purposes capable of doing absolutely
anything whether that be something
simple like conjuring a new computer or
quite possibly wiping out all existence
in the blink of an eye as we know it you
know Thanos style so nanan cut really is
like nothing the human broham has ever
seen it is a potentially extinction
level threat that has somehow appeared
amongst the zoldak family and there are
some pretty good reasons for both of
those first up we have the rather
straightforward facts revealed in the
extras of vol 33 that nanika is indeed
from the Dark Continent and it also has
another little handy word next to it
being I and you'll understand why that
is extraordinarily important very
shortly but this makes everything a
shade clearer because everything we know
regarding the colossal landmass that is
a dark continent which we actually know
quite a bit and I do have a video
detailing all of that information if
you'd care to watch but we're not Iike
stands out as an apocalyptic presence in
the human realm
they are simply part of the regular
ecosystem of the Dark Continent as
almost every known being from that
location has the potential to wipe out
all of humanity even the more mundane
looking creatures so non occurs from the
Dark Continent that's fun and probably
the only decent explanation that this
world could have given us but in the end
that doesn't really give us any new
information regarding nanika what I want
to know is exactly what nanika is and
how it made its way back to the human
settlement in the center of Lake Mobius
and luckily enough that information is
more readily available than you may
think
to begin this exploration I'd like to
introduce or reintroduce you to the idea
of the calamities also known as the five
threats and these terrifying specimens
are life-forms from the Dark Continent
that humanity has been forced to bring
back with them after an unsuccessful
voyage I guess you could think of them
as a curse or a punishment in
upon those intended to teach humanity a
lesson this practice is implemented by
an even more mysterious being known as
the guide who is summoned by a group of
magical beasts known as the gatekeeper
Oh gatekeepers blur oh I'm not clear on
that but they are currently the only
known method of humankind actually
gaining passage to the dark continents
to begin with however with this in mind
it would make total sense for nanika to
have appeared in the human realm as a
result of one of these ill-fated
expeditions and rather fascinatingly
that just so happens to be one calamity
that fits the description of nanika
pretty damn perfectly being the gaseous
eye form known as I there's that word
again
hi now before I continue I do want to
mention that Takashi has never in any
way shape or form confirmed that nanika
and I are the same being of the same
race of being whatever it may be
however the overwhelming evidence is
about as close to confirmation as any of
us should need so to begin I is
allegedly the result of a voyage made by
the member Republic who were seeking out
a mother solution for all sorts of
liquids on the dark continent and that
voyage returned with a total of three
survivors around Earth at number three
it may or may not be very important
later on but for now let's also take in
eyes full title which is codependence of
desire a gaseous life-form hi two very
very interesting words sir because
nanika exists as a codependent being and
its power is based on the idea of wishes
or desires both from my car and those
around them quick semantic note is well
being codependent is not the same as
coexisting or symbiotic in fact
codependency is a much more unhealthy
relationship as it generally involves
one party encouraging or enabling a
negative feature of another such as
addiction immaturity or any number of
mental health issues and that very much
rings true to some degree in the case of
a Luka and nanika nanika has effectively
possessed Holika and in return that
forces her to comply with Nana cos wish
granting powers by having a la cosmic
escalating requests of those around her
in direct correlation to the scale of
the previous wish that had been granted
by nanika and yes I referred to alcohol
and no I'm not going to get into the
great gender discussion of Hunter hunter
in this video because that's a topic for
an entirely different day but for now
that's how it's going to be in any case
the wish-granting is more complicated
than I've made it out to be essentially
what needs to happen is three of
aliquots requests need to be met which
can be very simple like pick me up or
carry me over there rather easy and
innocent desires at first anyway after
the third request has been fulfilled
Nanticoke will
emerge and at this point whoever happens
to be in the vicinity at the time can
ask Monica for literally anything and
Nanako will grant it kind of like the
eternal dragon but without so many fussy
rules well so interestingly this isn't
something you pick up on when reading on
watching the English version of Hunter
hunter but nanika has a particular
speech quirk when granting a wish in the
VIS manga translation nanika says kay
sort of referring to a slightly more
casual lazy and even possibly more
childish way of saying okay however in
japanese nanika says i look there's that
word again
which is very much the exact same sort
of speech quirk though except it's in
relation to the japanese for it hai
which every basic anime or manga fan
will know simply means yes so i is sort
of this cutesy way of saying yes but in
addition to that it just so happens to
be the name of one of the five threats
as well as their distinctive call which
you can see in that one panel we have of
the gaseous life-form say that speech
bubble right there it says hi so that's
one hell of a mighty coincidence we have
going on here so far fact that nanika is
a codependent wish-granting powerhouse
who frequently says i while the calamity
i is also a codependent desire focused I
saying life-form weird eh
well the coincidences don't even stop
there to get into our next one though
let's first reiterate the kicker of non
occurs power which is that the greater
the wish granted was the harder Ilocos
next request will be to fulfill for
example on one occasion a zoldak family
servant requested that nanika make her a
millionaire a wish that was met with a
torrent of currency showering down upon
the two of them however as a result
aleka's next requests were taken to a
whole new level as she asked for a liver
intestines a spine and even a brain none
of which she ended up receiving which
was very rude of the person aleca was
asking i mean to simply just refuse all
of her requests like that kind of person
would do that but this brings us swiftly
to what occurs if a person refuses a
total of four of Arcos requests which is
that they are immediately killed in some
of the most brutal ways imaginable and
not only that but depending on the scale
of the wish one death is not enough to
balance non occurs power and those
closest to the person who refused our
workers requests will also immediately
be killed until an appropriate cost has
been reached so for example in the case
of wishing for $1,000,000 or not dollars
whatever the currency of hunter hunter
is Jenny I guess given that jenny is
almost a one-to-one representation of
Japanese yen and I guess it would have
been wishing for a billion Jenny but I
digress the cost for such a way
would be the death of 67 people
including the servant who denied a
lockers requests but what I'm more
interested in is the method in which
nanika kills which is very vividly
demonstrated to us on one occasion where
another servant was ordered not to
fulfill all his desires and paid the
price by being crushed until they were
nothing but a puddle of blood and limbs
splattered across the floor that all
we've also seen Anika's victims get rung
to similar effect kind of like trying to
get water out of a towel and that brings
us to the containment facility of the
five threats and their victims which
were showcased in Chapter 341 featuring
many examples of people both having been
crushed or rung to death in exactly the
same fashion as we have been shown
nanika capable of doing furthermore [ __ ]
freaks is rather straightforwardly
stated that there have been confirmed
victims of both paths and I in the human
realm already and the victims I'm
referring to definitely don't fit
perhaps establish methodology leaving us
with a very very narrow pool of options
full of one really and look at this
point I would never say that it's 100%
guaranteed simply because it hasn't
literally been stated but everything
we've been showing regarding Monica and
I effectively confirms them to be the
same life-form I will say that the only
part that doesn't quite obviously add up
yet is the fact that I is a gaseous
existence but does not appear that way
when possessing a locker if anything
nanika seems more like a broad spiritual
creature but it could be a simple
explanation of AI infiltrating its hose
to fire its gaseous form and then taking
root in them transforming into a new
codependent creature and yes you can put
stock in other ideas such as the fact
that there may very well be more
calamities from the Dark Continent
present in the human world that we
simply aren't officially aware of and
the chimera ants are a very good example
of that actually they just sort of
appeared in this world and very rapidly
presented themselves as a threat to all
humankind so it's not impossible that
nanika is despite every similarity to I
an undocumented existence but my final
question in regards to nanika might
clear this up somewhat because it's also
very much worth asking why Nanako
possessed Alec as all dick to begin with
and at first it would seem like a nice
storytelling convenience you know the
one power that could save gone just so
happened to be right within killer's
reach but there may be more to the
zoldak connection than that
in fact we have at least one confirmed
instance of a member of the Zeltiq
family visiting the Dark Continent
beings exotic who joined a young Isaac
natural
no dearth a trio if you will and if you
remember earlier I stated that the
voyage that returned with I had only
three survivors I was fun in
mind-blowing is that maybe I should
point out that this by far the weakest
piece of evidence I'll be presenting in
this video because it has also been
stated that amongst those three
survivors each of them had gone mad and
furthermore Jing referred to the trip
that naturally took with Zeke and then
as undocumented so it's quite unlikely
that I and Zig are connected in that way
but still I thought it would be worth
mentioning that as all dick has been
associated with the Dark Continent given
that a creature from so continent has
now possessed one of their family
members in any case there you have it
there as it turns out nanika for such a
mysterious being is actually the life
form from the Dark Continent
that we happen to know the most about
with the exception of the chimera ants I
guess and luckily for the entire human
realm killer seems to have nanika under
control for now but that pretty much
does it for this exploration of exactly
what Monica is if you enjoyed this video
when the content this channel produced
in general then please do consider
donating to the new world review patreon
because the support of all of your
amazing people is what continues to make
this channel possible and if patreon
isn't quite your style then please do
leave this video a like share or
subscribe because it also helps support
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
area takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on nanika this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time
[Music]
do you plan to go into other manga like
black clover or anymore my hero academia
I'm not sure to be honest with you I
mean I've never read like clover despite
a whole ton of you guys telling me to
and don't probably get around to it one
day but my hero academia as much as I
love it I don't know how much I'm going
to feature it here it's a bizarre series
because I go through highs and lows with
it where I'll be completely obsessed one
day and then just forget about it the
next key aura just wondering when you
first started watching Hunter hunter and
at what point did you I guess fall for
the series so to speak keep up with
quality content Chiara my Kiwi friend
thanks for the kind words and the point
at which hunter hunter really got me was
the beginning of heavens arena and
specifically the introduction of nen it
was such a perfect hook giving you this
grand tournament ish almost game style
scenario combined with starting to
uncover the power system that the series
had been toying around with in the
background up until that point Boskone
versus oka was absolute brilliance did
you know that Bungie gum has the
properties of both rubber and gum you
you have blown my mind